christine is with us in boise idaho
hi christine what's up hi dave
thank you so much for your program i
appreciate your ministry
thank you um yeah i have a problem
i just love what you are teaching and
i'm so confirmed with it
but i have completely failed to get my
husband on board
and i just can't wait for him
to get on board so i am wondering how
can i move forward with the baby states
don't
uh without him because he don't
you're gonna end up divorced don't do
that
he has completely refused to go to
marriage counseling
and we just can't see eye to eye so it's
fine i already regret finances have you
gone to the marriage counselor
i have good keep going are you talking
to your pastor are you in a good church
keep going keep talking to them get some
advice on the relationship and let's get
this relationship rebuilt
and deal with that don't use the money
thing as a club to try to make him
go along with you on anything
it's not going to work it hasn't worked
so far and it drives a wedge it doesn't
heal
so the biggest thing is that i have been
very co-dependent in our relationship
for a very long time
and um which has kind of
encouraged him not to work
so i feel like that does not mean that
doesn't mean you can go off
on your own and start handling money
separately and end up anything but being
separate
showed us what he has decided for us to
do
no i do not know he doesn't get to
decide everything that's not how it
works
you have a relationship and you are
getting coached on how to manage through
this codependent
how to manage the codependence out of
this relationship
and once that part is healed then we can
talk about
how to work the money together but i'm
not going to tell you to run off to the
side over here and start doing the baby
steps
and keep telling him how wonderful it is
and how stupid he is
because that's not going to end up
anywhere good it'll end the relationship
yeah you know they've got to ask this
question
um i'm pretty sure america was shocked
to hear you say
don't because you're saying you got to
fix the marriage in a relationship
first because the probability of her
building wealth on the side
is and staying married yeah is zero yeah
there's i've almost got
no data points that that occurred you
know you
because you're it's like we have a bad
marriage so let's have a baby
you know it's not it's a dumb idea yes
sir okay we have a bad marriage so i'm
gonna go over here and handle money
no it's dumb idea we gotta work on the
relationship and
then you can work on the money then you
can talk about babies
this is the dave ramsey show